now in some sense this is a bit like a
mini budget from richie sunak but no
red book and no costings on precisely
how much
uh this is going to set back taxpayers
we do know though it's not going to be
quite as big as
many of the schemes we've heard about so
far this summer remember the photo
scheme
other things this tops all of them up
the higher it is the more we're spending
when you take it all public services the
furlough
business measures welfare you're talking
about 142 billion pounds a lot
a lot of money take today's measures and
you're talking about maybe five billion
maybe ten billion you can see in
contrast it really is quite small
i should say there's a few other things
we're talking about that the chancellor
mentioned too so an extra two billion
pound going into the track and trace
uh assist in the test track and trace
system that's 12 billion pounds in total
why have you got four aircraft carriers
because actually it's equivalent to the
cost
of four aircraft carriers a lot of money
about 400 pounds
per person in the uk but the big focus
really is on this that job support
scheme
how does it work well if you're working
few hours so working 33
of your normal hours you would get 77
pay 55 of it paid by your employer 22
by the government that's the theory but
the question is whether employers and
employees are actually going to take it
up
and also what it means for the labour
market because we know that a lot of
people are still on the furlough scheme
if you look across the labour market
this bar kind of breaks it down you can
see
a lot of people back at work now some
working remotely but still one in ten
on the photo scheme even in september
that's about three to four
million workers now those jobs are under
question we're not quite sure if those
jobs are going to come back some of them
might be saved by this
but some might not it's worth saying as
well for the smallest companies you're
talking about
one in five still on the furlough scheme
so big question marks about what happens
to the labour market here's what the
chancellor had to say
about that we don't want people
to be disadvantaged as best we can by
what's happening which is why we've put
in place
i think incredibly generous improvements
to our welfare system
through the increases in universal
credit the local housing allowance which
helps people with their rental payments
if they need it
we created a hardship fund for local
authorities
for those of their vulnerable citizens
who are struggling with council tax
payments
something we've put in place a range of
things to help the most vulnerable
now it's worth saying although the uk
has certainly spent a lot of money
on these schemes actually when you look
at the percentage of gdp and compare us
to other countries around the world
we've spent less than the u.s we spent
less than india canada
a lot less than germany and a third of
what japan has
so it may well be that there's room for
more spending yet to come
from the chancellor